vous avez fréquenté quand vous étiez pas
trop de canal des tas de gens que nous
allions amener
une journée c'est les gens importants
que vous appelez des fois ils sont là
des fois ils sont pas là et quand il
s'empale à vouloir laisser un message
sur leur messagerie et on va faire une
interview messagerie
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
jean marie messier veuillez laisser un
message après le bip sonore c'est à vous
je te merde
bonjour
de quelle carte il va donner non kardex
abidjan paris mais si les braves bouge
l'adorent selon rambo si
on va la garder cox avez vous êtes sur
la messagerie d'andré rousselet veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous je sais pas comment
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours je pourrais
vous remercier de nous avoir donné cette
liberté là bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie d'elvis presley pour laisser
un message à peine au bip sonore de
tavaux alors toujours morts
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
michel denisot pour laisser un message
c'est à vous on peut avoir du talent et
pas voir beaucoup de gueule
des gens
vous êtes sur la messagerie d'alain
chabat pour laisser un message c'est à
vous recevrai demain comme hier
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
michel le petit actionnaires ruinés par
vivendi universal
je suis content de voir que vous vous
refaites un peu et qu'on est si on met
pas tout l'argent dans la fondation de
jean rené fourtou pouvez-vous
bonjour j'ai sur les singeries de
bertrand méheut plus un message à peine
le bip sonore sans tabou merci de votre
appel monsieur pour me convier comme
vous l'avez fait à déjeuner avec vous
avant que vous déménagiez de l'immeuble
de canal je veux bien les jeunes avec
vous mais pas forcément dans l'immeuble
a moqué vidé bonjour vous êtes sur un
message lui donnait de graves pour
laisser un message un peu le bip sonore
c'est à vous quand est-ce que tu
remontes à paris bonjour vous êtes sur
messagerie de steven spielberg y laisser
un message après le bip sonore c'est à
vous j'espère vous voir en juillet
puisque le jeu on s'est croisé à paris
m'a dit qu'il devait tourner en juillet
et que on verra ce moment là bonjour
c'est sur la messagerie d'antoine de
caunes peut laisser un message après le
bip sonore c'est tabou quand tu reviens
de trouville arrête toi à paris bonjour
vous êtes sur la messagerie de patrick
le lay pour laisser un message après le
bip sonore c'est à vous
je me demande pourquoi j'ai fait votre
numéro
bonjour bien sur la messagerie de
stéphane bern l'islamiste après le bip
sonore c'est à vous franchement depuis
le début de l'année je trouve que tu te
démerdes est pas trop mal un à cannes
c'est pas tout à fait ça le cinéma c'est
pas trop son truc il faudra forcément un
truc qu'on sait bien faire bonjour les
sur des messageries madame lescure
s'agit d'une heure et demie je suis là
dakar sauf si on bouffe en sommeil
d'arbres mais bon dans trois heures et
demie demain matin 10 ans d'égarement il
a dit allez andy demain à lundi
bonjour j'ai sur ma messagerie de pierre
lescure ou laisser un message après le
bip sonore c'est à vous toujours mégalo
mon coeur est maintenant c'est
l'interview boîte vocale
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie des
monty python si vous nous avez piqué des
sketches veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore c'est à vous claque
moi j'ai raccroché
on leur a rien volé à l'averse de
certains que certains autres maires des
monty python qui ne nous ont volé des
trucs qu'on avait l'intention de faire
un creux les gars longtemps après
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie
d'ophélie winter si vous êtes prêts à
faire la une de voici veuillez laisser
un message après le bip sonore c'est à
vous salue ici d'homme ça va
bonjour vous êtes sur un message michel
drucker merci beaucoup de m'appeler
vraiment merci veuillez laisser votre
message après le bip sonore temps on va
tâcher n
allait pas la famille bonjour vous êtes
sur la messagerie de bruno karachi
absent pour le moment mais laissez votre
message après le bip sonore
pourquoi moi le surtout qu'on sait c'est
qu'à un moment ou à un autre être revoir
ouais ouais ouais ouais bon jour bien
sûr et messagerie de bertrand méheut si
vous avez l'esprit canal veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous
salue ces dom savoir
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
steven spielberg je sais ça calme
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore
c'est gentil ça va on le fera pas ce
film donc ça va de toute façon tu as pas
les moyens donc laisse tomber tu feras
pas l'intégrer de 3,9 à
hautmont c'est non
bonjour vous êtes sur les messageries de
jean marie messier si c'est pas pour de
l'argent veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore n9 jean-marie
toujours la moitié de 18
qu'est ce que tu veux
bonjour bien sur la messagerie de nicole
kidman si vous êtes dominique farrugia
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore nicole je suis pris les ce mois
ci subit ça suffit je rappellerai que
même après bonjour vous êtes son ami
cergy de ppda je suis chez mon coiffeur
vous alors veuillez laisser votre
message ça devrait être rapide tu peux
me rappeler qu'aucun
aujourd'hui l'émission de stéphane bern
gardien de l'esprit canal veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
garde le bien
[Rires]
bonjour vaisseau les messageries des
nuls nous sommes en tournée le vin chez
ardisson le 25 chez denisot le 26 chez
cauet de 27 ch et chiens de 28 chez
pascal classe le 22 à asnières
complémentaires 34 veuillez laisser
votre message après le bip sonore s'il
vous plaît nous serons aussi en
signature à la fnac le 31 est le propre
de et quelqu'un une vanne oui le tram 2
c'est pas possible ah bah
alors on va imaginer laurent etc et que
vous appeliez tout ce que vous mettez en
cause dans votre livre et que vous leur
laissez un message en livre après vous
servir de bandits oui on va faire
l'interview messagerie
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
josé bové vous pouvez laisser un message
c'est à vous à l'eau josé j'espère que
tu vas bien mais il faudrait vraiment
que tu te rases les moustaches parce que
franchement ils sont jaunes elles sont
en forme de m à chaque fois tu vois ta
gueule j'ai envie d'aller bouffer chez
mcdo
bonjour j'ai sur le répondeur de carole
rousseau j'ai une idée d'émission pour
vous ça s'appellerait scrupules c'est à
dire ce serait encore pire que scrupules
et j'ai même le générique de l'émission
se serait on va tomber encore plus bas
c'est la faute à voltaire on va tomber
dans le ruisseau c'est la faute à
rousseau
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sur le répondeur de bernadette
chirac fois laissé un message à l'eau
bernadette est ce que vous êtes bien
reçu votre brumisateur
vous êtes sur le programme de michael
jackson pourrait laisser un message
à l'aube orbi déjà beaucoup un peu
intime à l'aube ordi je sais pas il
paraît que tout et procèdent coûte la
peau des fesses alors qu'est ce qui va
te rester
[Musique]
fatigués quand même c'est bizarre parce
qu'ils appellent bambi et ses lentilles
pinocchio parce que plus il manque plus
on est ce raccourci
[Musique]
vous êtes sur votre coeur de florent
pagny et ce pour laisser un message à
florent pagny et écoute si tu passes à
bercy pense pas à passer au ministère
des finances c'est tout voilà
bonjour sur le répondeur de nicolas
sarkozy police et votre message je lui
dirai nicolas arrête de te laisser
pousser les oreilles ça commence à
énerver son automne de chirac
bonjour j'ai sur le répondeur de janet
jackson connaissez votre message janet
je t'ai vu montré un sein mtv awards
choix interne aux mtv awards arrête de
faire ces conneries là parce que jane
birkin va faire la même chose aux
victoires de la musique
j'ai un écran plat alors je vais rien à
voir
bonjour j'ai lu sur le répondeur de
dieudonné bon spectacle parce que c'est
là où tu es le meilleur c'est sur scène
donc continuer à faire du spectacle un
peu moins de politique parce que
franchement
heureusement que c'est coluche qui a
ouvert les restos du coeur si ç'avait
été toi dieudo il y aurait eu d'à côté
les restos halal et de l'autre les
restos cacher
j'ai fait sur le répondeur je me dis que
je suis imposé ces passages salués naudy
donc à peine élu et déjà enfermé en
prison tu vas plus vite que les autres
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux